[Music]
hello and welcome to this video
yeah in this video which is part three
chapter 3 of our video course on how to
fight if all our honor we will look for
the first time at the starting moves of
the petrov which is some yeah the
sequence black plays Knight f6 just
answering symmetrically to White's
attack on the e5 pawn so both sides
actually now have a pawn attacked in
this same position the most popular
moves for white a Knight takes e5 this
is by far the most popular and then
there is also deform those two moves
actually Adam yeah the main chunk of the
Petroff white however does not need to
play exactly those moves of course there
are other options and the video three
part three will deal with white playing
either Knight c3 Bishop c4 or do you
three other moves don't really make all
that much sense I mean black is
attacking this pawn so it makes sense to
either yeah increase the pressure on the
pawn if I felt like d4 does or take it
what Effendi for those some read the
most logical options Bishop c4 is a
gambit line that we will also check I
need to mention that after Knight c3 I
recommend to play knight c6 which
transposes into the four Knights opening
and one big part of that is Bishop b5 in
this position I can put it on the board
or deform and those two lines are dealt
with in chapter 4 a little bit too
chunky to put it into into one chapter I
tried that initially but it was just too
much so I split this into
two chapters it's easier to digest this
way so in this chapter we will look at
the four Knights the rare for Knights
and we will check all the deviations
here on move three that white may play
and those are really not very dangerous
but it's useful that you have a look the
first move that I want to check is the
move d3 yeah I'm very conservative move
that cannot really endanger us all that
much but okay it's worth looking at
briefly white cover c4 and now II five
is indeed attacked so I recommend to
play 96 very logical in a book by
Konstantin Sakai F sake F recommends to
play d6 instead which is feels a little
bit passive but it's playable and not a
bad option he goes d6 and g6 but 96 is
super logical yeah here White has tried
mostly two more he has to decide whether
he wants to put the bishop here on e2 or
whether he wants to fianchetto and these
are the two options that we should check
let's start with Bishop e2 if white
wants to play that way of course he can
also play Knight bTW to first and then
Bishop e2 it's not a big a big
difference what we will do is we'll play
d5 and this is something that I will
emphasize throughout the videos and also
emphasized throughout the text it is
absolutely essential to see that if
black and manages to play d5 in the
petrov or in general in the open games
and manages to play it without being in
some way punished or in some way having
problems afterwards then usually you
have solved your opening problems and
this is no exception we immediately see
that like should be fine here we've got
easy development and good central play
yeah white now has a choice between
taking on d5 and playing that BD to the
move
eat xt5 and this has become a little bit
more popular in recent years it still
obscure in comparison but it was played
more than let's say twenty years ago
their point probably is that after
Knight takes white castles and this
particular way of playing is basically
philidor's defense with reverse colors
this early d3 white is basically playing
the role that black plays in the finis
doors and is a tempo up and that makes a
difference in some lines for example in
them in the wide repertoire that I've
released so keep it simple efore against
the footy doors I recommend to play a g3
based setup but here g6 is not so great
because white has a favorable move d4 in
this position so we have to play
differently here and I suggest to play
Bishop to d6 just very normal develop
the bishop prepare castling and cover u5
rook e1 castles is very normal
h3 trying to prevent Bishop g4 from
happening and now I move like Bishop f5
gives black very decent play this is not
a forced move of course Bishop f5 you
can also play differently but something
with Queen d7 next and centralize rooks
is a good plan in general this is a very
solid way of playing it is not very
enterprising what white is doing but
you're not going to win quickly with
like you're just centralized and be
happy that you have all those a good
developing moves and good central
control the capture on d5 cannot trouble
us all that much more often still more
often after d5 why displaying that be d2
and covers this pawn and throws attacked
after all and here indeed we have the
closed Philidor with colors reversed in
the philidor's with white i always
recommend to play the Bishop to c4 so
our development here with Bishop c5 is
extremely logical what we have to be
aware of is that now in this opening the
white play is more
set up then a concrete string of moves
that is just going to happen like like
clockwork and there's no combination or
anything happening why displaying a
bunch of moves in a basic claim flexible
move on them moves like c3 a3 b3
castling rook e1 and so on there are
just some rule of rules of thumb that I
want to want to tell because there is I
think all you need to know whenever they
play C 3 or a 3 and try to push before
we should always play the move a5 this
is very important we should not give
white an easy opportunity to expand
their on the Queen side whenever before
it's played and they have Bishop b2 and
so on just stop it with the a pawn
that's very important I think that you
need to know that you should not take on
e4 all that frequently you should have a
very clear reason for doing that because
if we trade the two points we would
activate the white bishop instead of
changing the pawn structure in any way
it is usually better for black to get
simply improve the position and keep the
tension moves like rook e8 Bishop a7 h6
those moves should a7 not h7 and rupee
eight these are useful
just keep the tension I don't think you
need to know much more if you play the
white side of the philidor's for example
you know what you're going to do it is
something that would happen very rarely
and it does not really yeah put us under
under lots of pressure really and if we
go back to that position on move three
more interesting maybe in comparison is
to move g3 white is trying to fianchetto
it and basically play the Kings Indian
attack setup so we're going to play d5
then it's not a surprise and now again
White has this choice between keeping
the tension
and taking on d5 if they keep the
tension and we could do the same by
playing Bishop c5 but it is actually a
very simple solution to take him on you
for I put the bishop on to c5 the
capture makes our life a little bit
easier because we don't have to think
about constantly if why it takes what
happens and here the capture is another
concession really compared to Bishop e2
Alliance because the white bishop sits
on g2 anyway and so we don't activate
the bishop because it's on g2 yeah and
after something like that black has a
fine game their idea is to play b3 and
Bishop sorry b6 and Bishop a6 and this
will be very comfortable
another very more creative way to view
this position is if we go all the way
back a little bit of a detour in the
French defense white sometimes place the
move d3 yeah and black one of blacks
most reliable responses is this where
black enters the whole thing here with a
tempo down and it has the reputation of
being completely fine for black
so we basically enter this whole thing
with the tempo up okay after G 3 D 5 we
still have to check what happens if
white captures
okay of course we recapture Bishop g2 if
you enjoyed the free video preview make
sure to go to chesterlaw.com slash fight
like a Khurana to get to the full course
the full course with the move trainer
and video sync technology is an
excellent way to learn all the ideas and
strategies connected to this repertoire
these lines were essential in Kiwanis
fight to get the world title match and
they can be an essential part of your
opening repertoire as well
[Music]